I feel like I'm a bit of a jellybean
expert
I could definitely guess black licorice
is close here's the nose plug it's
literally just like dissolving sugar in
my mouth it doesn't taste like anything
jelly
maybe bean flavored no I'd say that was
green whatever it green is okay got it
this one actually it has like a a
cinnamon taste and breathe out of it oh
whoa like a rush of flavor just came
through oh man I hate black licorice I
couldn't taste it at all but now I just
that's all I taste I look real silly
right now I can't smell it
oh [ __ ] that's nuts they do taste very
similar
[Music]
the white wine I took a wine-tasting
class when you're supposed to like swirl
it smells like a lot of white wines I've
had in my day Mama's had a lot of wine
in her day that's pretty good
all right this is a red breads not
usually my go-to it's pretty good as
well I feel like I like this one more
but I don't know why but this will go
nice with like a good noodle feels
earthy heavy body the white wine I like
the white butter it's fresh crisp
oh no way seriously are you sure oh well
from did taste really good
[Music]
I'm gonna try this this one in the white
mug here one I feel like this one does
appear thicker a little more bitter than
what I was expecting the first one is
like slightly more bitter this won't
taste like hot chocolate - it's less
bitter than that one I feel like that
one's coffee and this one's like an
actual hot chocolate I think I like the
orange one a little bit better if it was
warmer it would take the cake but they
don't taste the same hey you had this is
this is evil
don't believe you not the same
but they don't taste the same
[Music]